erneuerbare energien sind toll sie
produzieren sauberen strom den wir für
alles mögliche nutzen können aber was
ist wenn der wind weht und die sonne
scheint
mit diesem strom gerade aber gar nicht
brauchen wie kann man dieses überangebot
an energie sinnvoll nutzen
gleichzeitig gibt es viele bereiche in
unserem leben die von sauberen strom
überhaupt nicht profitieren egal wie
grüner ist flugzeuge zum beispiel
niemand will sich das fliegen verbieten
lassen die einen müssen geschäftlich
reisen
die anderen wollen die welt sehen nur
pusten flugzeuge jeden tag unmengen an
co2 in die luft
diese probleme sind bekannt und es gibt
viele technologien start-ups und ideen
die versuchen diese probleme zu lösen
eine dieser lösungen fand ich aber
besonders interessant power tricks die
umwandlung von erneuerbare energie in
andere stoffe zum beispiel gase
kunststoffe oder kraftstoffe bald wird
die bundesregierung ihre wasserstoff
strategie beschließen und patrick spielt
dabei eine zentrale rolle
denn grüner wasserstoff ist das ergebnis
wenn man mit hilfe von nachhaltigem
strom wasser durch elektrolyse in
wasserstoff und sauerstoff umwandelt und
wasserstoff ist bei vielen power tricks
verfahren ein wichtiges zwischenprodukt
das ist zum beispiel auch in karlsruhe
der fall
und deswegen sind wir für euch da
hingefahren um uns mal ein beispiel
dieser technologie genauer anzuschauen
[Musik]
hier am karlsruher institut für
technologie steht die weltweit erste
integrierte anlage die co2 aus der luft
saugt und daraus kraftstoffe wie benzin
diesel oder kerosin herstellen kann
integriert heißt hier alle schritte vom
luft einsaugen bis zum kraftstoff
ausspucken passieren in diesem einen
container gebaut wurde die anlage im
kopernikus projekt power 2x das vom
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung gefördert wird
das beste an der anlage ist wenn der
strom der hierfür benötigt wird
erneuerbar ist und wir den co2 ausstoß
für den bau der anlage jetzt mal
ignorieren dann ist die gesamte
herstellung co2 neutral
man könnte also theoretisch mit dem auto
fahren das co2 das dabei entsteht
einfangen daraus wieder kraftstoff
herstellen und hätte kein zusätzliches
co2 in die umwelt gebracht
klingt fast schon zu gut um wahr zu sein
und hier muss ich euch leider
enttäuschen das hier ist zwar die
zukunft aber nicht die eine technologie
die den klimawandel aufhalten wird
während wir alle weiterhin normale
verbrenner autos fahren können warum das
so ist dazu später mehr
zuerst wollte ich mir einmal erklären
lassen wie diese anlage überhaupt
funktioniert deswegen habe ich michael
klumpp gefragt michael ist gruppenleiter
am kit und arbeitet mit am kopernikus
projekt power chi-x
das ganze beginnt letzter nicht damit
dass ihr zunächst die luft ansaugen aus
der umgebung und diese anlage von
unserem projektpartner klein wirkt das
co2 aus der luft filtert und wir das co2
dann von den späteren prozess nutzen
können also das was wir gerade ausatmen
wird gleich zu kraftstoffen verarbeitet
beim pusten würden beziehungsweise ein
städter steckten die plätze dahinter
dass die luft ansaugen und hinten steckt
nation der bayerische selektiv des co2
aus der luft bindet und die saubere co2
freie luft verpesten
damit hat das co2 gewonnen das war schon
mal ein erster wichtiger rohstoff
verdient kohlenwasserstoffe das sie
brauchen kohlenstoff und der grünen
stoff steckt in diesem co2 jetzt wollen
auch noch wasserstoff für die
kohlenwasserstoffe und dieser wird
generiert in der so genannten
hochtemperatur co elektrolyse das steckt
in mir drin
und warum ist teilt elektronik liegt
sicherlich daran dass ihr co2 und
wasserdampf simultan gemeinsam in die
elektronische schicken zähler hoch das
heißt co2 weise gerade gewonnen haben
zusammen mit wasserdampf der tat
umgesetzt wird den sogenannten
synthesegas ist schon mischung aus
kohlenmonoxid und wasserstoff für die
hochtemperatur co elektrolyse wird im
industriellen maßstab ein sehr guter
wirkungsgrad von ungefähr 80 prozent
erwartet das heißt dass wir immerhin
vier fünftel des eingesetzten ökostroms
chemisch in synthesegas binden können
möglich macht das eine technologie des
unternehmens an feier- und dass die
anlage die wärme die in späteren
schritten anfällt nutzt um den
energiebedarf der ko elektrolyse zu
verringern
nach der kuh elektrolyse wird das
synthesegas zum dritten schritt weiter
geleitet und das ist das sogenannte
fischer tropsch verfahren
hierbei werden aus dem synthesegas
langkettige kohlenwasserstoff moleküle
gebildet dazu benutzt das startup im
irak dass das modul für diesen schritt
gebaut hat einen sehr kompakten
mikrostrukturierten reaktor die
mikrostrukturen im reaktor erlauben dass
auch viel kleinerem raum chemische
reaktionen ebenso effektiv ablaufen wie
in normalen reaktoren das ergebnis der
fischer tropsch synthese ist dann quasi
schon das was wir als kraftstoff
bezeichnen
im letzten schritt wird dann die
qualität dieses kraftstoffes noch einmal
optimiert
hier werden die kohlenwasserstoff hätten
die zu lang sind mit hilfe eines platin
zeolith katalysators aufgespalten
das nennt man auch heidrun tracking am
ende spuckt die anlage dann drei
verschiedene stoffe aus zum einen ganz
normales wasser zum anderen ein
hochreines wachs dass man mit
kerzenwachs vergleichen kann und das zum
beispiel für die chemie industrie
interessant ist und als drittes
natürlich unser evtl
den kann man allerdings so nicht direkt
in sein auto füllen und damit losfahren
vorher müssen die kohlenwasserstoff
ketten noch in gängigen raffinerie
prozessen aufbereitet werden
je nachdem ob man benzin diesel oder
kerosin haben möchte ist das
unterschiedlich aufwendig
gerade wird allerdings daran geforscht
auch das direkt in der anlage zu machen
okay aber ist synthetisch hergestellter
kraftstoff für mein motor irgendwie
schlechter als herkömmlicher im
gegenteil die synthetischen kraftstoffen
lassen sie sogar maßschneidern das heißt
ich kann noch gezielter die
eigenschaften so einstellen dass sie
perfekt sind für die verbrennung die
größere haben sogar das potential noch
sauberer zu sein als die aus den
fossilen quellen weil wir eben keine
verunreinigungen drin haben die zum
beispiel schwefel oder ähnliches das
heißt die verbrennungseigenschaften sind
besser und sauberer als die von den
fossilen quellen bezogen kraftstoffe ein
extra bonus pools sind weitestgehend
geruchsneutral der typische tankstellen
geruch könnte also bald der
vergangenheit angehören
und weder flugzeuge noch lkw noch
schiffe müssten ihre motoren umbauen um
die fuels nutzen zu können
es ist also einfach sich ein perfektes
system vorzustellen
man könnte solche anlagen wie die des
kopernikus projektes überall dort bauen
wo viel erneuerbare energie erzeugt wird
die kraft wir gewonnen werden sind co2
neutral was natürlich hervorragend ist
aber letztendlich muss energie im
kraftstoff steckt irgendwo herkommen
die kommt sinnvollerweise nicht einig
werden das heißt sonne und wind strom
und jeder umwandlung schritt hat
natürlich gewisse verluste auch wir
haben hier mit gewissen verlusten zu
leben
das heißt nicht 100 prozent des stromes
denn ich von denen die
das heißt eingibt landet letztendlich
hinten mein produkt also der
bildungsgrad in jetzt hier für diese
prozesskette erwarten wenn wir in den
nächst größere aus hof schule gehen
liegt bei ungefähr 60 prozent das heißt
60 prozent der energie des stromes wenn
ich eins setzte landete letztendlich
brennwert von meinem produkt ein
typischer benzinmotor hat dann wiederum
nur einen durchschnittlichen
wirkungsgrad von circa 35 bis
allerhöchstens 45 prozent der rest wird
als wärme an die umwelt abgegeben
selbst im optimalfall gehen also
ungefähr 55 bis 65 prozent der erzeugten
energie verloren
ein batterie elektroauto hingegen kann
rund 90 prozent des stroms in bewegung
umsetzen
es werde also mit derselben energie bis
zu dreimal so weit würden wir alle autos
in zukunft einfach mit fuels betreiben
dann müssen wir noch viel mehr
zusätzliche windenergie und solaranlagen
bauen als wir sowieso schon bauen müssen
oder wir müssen strom in ländern
produzieren lassen die genügend
erneuerbare energien zur verfügung haben
länder in west oder südafrika zum
beispiel so oder so gehen die forscher
des kopernikus projektes davon aus dass
synthetischer kraftstoffe vor allem da
eingesetzt wird wo es absehbar keine
besseren alternativen gibt zum beispiel
in flugzeugen und schiffen die schlechte
energiedichte von batterien ergibt für
den einsatz in langstreckenflugzeugen
oder großen tankern einfach keinen sinn
außerdem dauert es lange bis aktuelle
schiffe und flugzeuge ausgetauscht
werden schließlich sind die betreiber
daran interessiert ihre investitionen so
lange wie möglich zu nutzen mit e fuels
könnten aber bereits heute flugzeuge und
schiffe sauberer gemacht werden bevor es
allerdings soweit ist muss noch einiges
passieren aktuell stellt die anlage in
karlsruhe
gerade einmal zehn liter kraftstoff am
tag her es reicht vielleicht für zwei
oder drei spritztour aber natürlich
werden diese ersten interview nicht
verfahren sondern von partnern des
kopernikus projektes analysiert die
anlage die wir uns hier ansehen durften
ist das ergebnis der ersten phase des
kopernikus projektes paar tricks vor
kurzem ist die zweite phase gestartet in
der eine neue und größere anlage bereits
200 bis 300 liter kraftstoff am tag
herstellen soll
und ab 2025 soll dann in der dritten
phase eine vorindustrielle version
gebaut werden die mehrere tausend liter
täglich produzieren kann
wann wir es aber tatsächlich im einsatz
sehen das ist leider noch unklar
wandern die
implementierung im markt stattfinde das
heißt wann wirklich flugzeugen fliegen
hängt von verschiedenen faktoren ab
da muss natürlich auch die industrie
beziehen unsere aufgabe als
forschungsinstitut ist diese technologie
bereitzustellen so verstehen zu
beherrschen so dass wir das auf mark
anbieten können und auch über den preis
pro liter fuel will man noch nicht sagen
aber wenn es dann so weit ist dann
könnten wir solche kompakten anlagen
theoretisch überall auf der welt
aufstellen natürlich am besten dort wo
sauberer strom produziert wird und wo
die anlagen womöglich auch noch ab wir
haben von anderen industrieprozessen
nutzen können ich finde das ist eine
mega coole möglichkeit um aus
nachhaltigen energien noch mehr
rauszuholen und gleichzeitig bereits
heute existierende flugzeuge und schiffe
und lkw klimafreundlicher zu machen
es wird nicht die eine lösung gegen den
klimawandel seien aber hoffentlich ein
teil davon
aber was sagt ihr dazu seht ihr diese
technologie jetzt schon neben windrädern
und solarpark stehen
oder seid ihr da ein bisschen kritischer
ich hab es mir gerne unten in die
kommentare was haltet ihr davon
zögert auch nicht mehr fragen zu stellen
falls ihr welche habt ansonsten vielen
dank an michael klumpp und an alle
kollegen vom kec in karlsruhe dafür dass
wir bei euch vor drehen durften und die
mir alle meiner vielen vielen fragen
beantwortet habt danke an den decken ev
und dem projektträger jülich für die
unterstützung bei diesem projekt und
vielen dank auch als bundesministerium
für bildung und forschung das das
kopernikus projekt power chi-x ins leben
gerufen hat und fördert die power to
fuel anlage in karlsruhe ist allerdings
nur ein kleiner teil des kopernikus
projektes powered access erforscht nicht
nur wie man strom und kraftstoff
umwandelt sondern auch in plastik
chemikalien oder kosmetika die
schwesterprojekte von karadzics synergie
und schuhe versuchen dagegen die
industrie und die stromnetze
klimafreundlich zu gestalten
wenn ihr wollt mache ich auch dazu gerne
ein video schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare wenn euch das interessieren
würde ansonsten wie immer
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig hattrick